[Music]
welcome everyone to the sold-out Staples
Center in downtown Los Angeles
California it's the home of the Lakers
will a broadcasting wide today for 2k
sports
beef stir up now the dish to Jordan it's
black ice shack grant with a screen on
Kobe the tribe bond chosen you use that
pick to get any clothes looks like he
might be on his game today
Rose hitch the joint uncovered yes in
the bottom three in the lead so I mean
you're just not gonna get away with
shooting that point and that one's good
shit's got his second button Pippen
launches it on number three for Chicago
get the ball inside into the paint even
with the pass a penetration shots good
by Pippen Baylor is screen on Rose and
with the slam really just pull that off
that was an outstanding play George
the fadeaway that is good scheme is a
very
areas rebounding is one thing
Jonathan Johnson dishes Romeo and now
it's a double-digit lead off on the
glass three Pippin it's good this time
the assist from Rose and that concludes
the first half
Lakers on top they're up by 10
[Music]
we'll be their most reliable offensive
approach which is the use of small
screens image pick and roll that's a
play we should be seeing a lot
probably a good time to make some
changes with a good chunk of the second
half still to go Kevin alright George
thanks
[Music]
O'Neil with it he's picked up by pimping
pony will pitch their duel Jabar vicious
Mason family
the true Jabbar has got two points
outside rose he can't be stopped
roses got ten points in the game
here's Bryant and there's another one
for the lady does not punish players
getting overly aggressive at these
defensive
the baseline jumper goes down
quickly their leaders
the course of the last few possession
and so Los Angeles takes the win
they saw they conquered